this year was to put it plainly kind of
a stunner for videogames no matter what
you're into there were wonderful
experiences to be had we got all
inspiring platformers glorious shooters
beautiful adventures and blockbuster
masterpieces well GameSpot too spent the
last couple of weeks celebrating those
I'm gonna tell you about the games that
for one reason or another just did not
nail it in 2016
sometimes bad games are bad because they
seem to be full of potential and end up
being a huge disappointment several
games from this year fell into that
category but I'm talking Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles mutants in Manhattan now
no one expected this one to be good
because it was a time to release with
the movie but a lot of people did expect
it to be good given it was created by
Bayonetta developer Platinum Games and
the studio's last movie related game
transformers devastation was actually
quite good mutants in Manhattan was a
whole other story it showed all the
floors of the game rushed out to meet a
film release featured a combat system
that didn't require any nuance beyond
button mashing and encounters that was
so chaotic that having more than one
enemy on screen made it impossible to
see what was going on platinum added in
items and an upgrade system to broaden
the gameplay experience but they proved
to be largely meaningless and the
delightful chatty exchanges between our
turtle bros were undermined by an
uninspired game world and boring
fighting given this one came from the
same studio who made game spots 10 out
of 10 rated action game Bayonetta 2
that's just not to quote the turtles
themselves radical controversial opinion
time
there's nothing all that wrong with
taking inspiration from great mechanics
or features and using them in your own
game what you don't want to do is
blatantly copy that game and do so
poorly Alekhine's gun actually has a
really enticing premise it sets you up
as a KGB agent working for the CIA in a
cold war-era thriller unfortunately the
game is almost a carbon copy of hitman
except that it doesn't really work it's
riddled with bugs and features the
dumbest most forgetful AI you'll ever
come across I'm talking shut a door in
these dudes faces and they'll forget you
ever their dumb movement is stilted the
controls are all
and the open-world design consists of
massive areas which are almost
completely empty if there was ever a
game that needed more time to cook its
Alekhine's gun sometimes a game arrives
on Steam early access and although it's
broken and buggy it's got a lot of
potential I mean that's what early
access is all about
sometimes that same game is released
with even more bugs on console with no
early access caveat and a lot of people
get very angry such is the case with the
otherwise rather popular zombie survival
game 7 days to die so how does a game
that has a 9 out of 10 user review
average on Steam end up with a 2 out of
10 for its console port well it's down
to crap visuals maddening loading times
endless glitches and an aiming system
that was in no way adapted to work with
controllers that's in addition to a
console port that appears to ignore
almost all the differences between PC
and consoles forcing you to use the
right thumbstick as an agonizingly slow
moving cursor to adjust items in your
inventory my advice keep to the pc
version of this one now we have a game
that nobody really had high expectations
for and it fully delivered on those low
expectations in a year that had games
like titanfall 2 battlefield 1 and
overwatch there really was no room for a
competitive multiplayer shooter that
tried to deliver a similar sort of
gun-toting experience and executed it
really really poorly and yet Capcom gave
us umbrella call almost universally
perceived as a fairly pointless addition
to the Resident Evil franchise umbrella
core really only succeeded in taking all
the shittiest parts of resi games that
is all the clunky action and no
substance or atmosphere and condensing
those parts into one shitty package the
game featured boring maps and unclear
and inconsistent cover system both
overly lengthy and broken animations
little incentive to progress and basic
uninteresting single-player levels oh
and technical issues a veritable [ __ ]
ton of them my last on this list is yet
another Activision published movie
tie-in that was a disaster in every
sense of the word
unfortunately ghosts weren't the only
things that got busted
the sixteenth attempt to make a
Ghostbusters game this one actually gets
a little tragic as Ghostbusters
developer fire Forge games filed for
bankruptcy three days after the release
of the game although that wasn't solely
due to the poor reception of
Ghostbusters the game was called
mind-numbingly boring by GameSpot
reviewer Jason de Priya who singled out
the fact that the game is a massive slog
thanks to its empty repetitious levels
shitty riding with lines like I'm the
MVP of a VP and half-baked features like
the upgrade system Ghostbusters does
manage to make both isometric twin-stick
shooters and Ghostbusters Games boring
so I guess it's got that going for it be
sure to let me know your picks for
crappiest game of the year in that
comment section down below
do yourself a favor and avoid these
terrible games over the break and have
yourself a lovely holiday
[Music]
you
[Music]